you know we'd love to have a season two
obviously and yeah we just want to see
more of the relationships between
everyone and like friendship yeah yeah
I'm rooting for a bloodbath but yeah I'm
rooting for death if we get a season two
if there's a way to save us I'd burn the
world down oh uh I'd be so down to do a
second season I think I speak for all of
us when I
um but I just I hope each character gets
to you know expand their story lines I
hope alanka you know she finally gets a
sense of validation towards the end and
I'm I'm curious as to see you know what
happens with that yeah I mean you know
if I was asked obviously I'd do it um
for
yeah I think I'd like to see like Dr
Stan I'm stealing ap's answer uh I'd
like to see Dr Stanton tell a story in
the club because everyone tells one
apart from her and I want to know what
Cherie's story is I want I need to know
I'm Dr Georgina Stanton welcome to
Bright Cliff so I told Mike I go next
season I hope fingers crossed I get to
tell a story of my own at the Midnight
Club table I would like to know more
about this mysterious Dr Stanton and you
know what the heck's going on with her
past and you know and what's going on
with her future you know it's a big
Cliffhanger at the end and you real you
reveal a lot about me that you never
expected right
me me the hobby all of my way
[Music]
that is totally up to Netflix but yeah
dude it'd be great
you guys totally up to audiences if they
love this show then which I think they
will
um yeah it's it's it's up to them
the thing I'd love to do is pull in some
of the more iconic Christopher Pike work
and marry it into this so yeah we have
we have a plan for season two if we're
lucky enough to have one and it's very
pike-centric I feel like it's a
Christopher Pike Russian doll will just
keep you know putting stories of
Christopher Pike within stories of
Christopher Mike and while we wait for
news on season two there is plenty to
love about season one it's lots of fun
horror Thrills you know spooky times but
it also has so much heart to it that's
kind of the biggest thing about the show
is you know it's all about the
relationships and the community that's
you know formed in the show and so yeah
yeah we can promise you uh cyborgs
witches
serial killers
we there's a lot of different monsters
as well
um yeah
personal Journey like you realize that
each story is really
um unique and uh deserves to be told so
yeah and they're all learning a lot and
from each other as well they're going
through this devastating thing but they
have this friendship and this openness
with one another that I think comes
through in their stories as well when
we're telling the scary stories um it
helps them kind of relate to each other
more I'm going to die I'm almost here
dying this is a hospice for sure lots of
humor a great sense of camaraderie and
family
um and a whole bunch of scares
yeah prepared to be emotionally wrecked
I would say yeah it's a roller coaster I
feel like it this show tackles themes of
friendship and love like we said before
but um yeah Mike does such a great job
of mixing all of us together and like
connecting us in ways that you wouldn't
expect so I feel like yeah whatever
expecting don't expect it you can never
expect anything from a bike Flanagan
show except for Easter eggs I think you
can expect those Christopher Pike was a
hugely formative part of my childhood so
I wanted to do a Christopher Pike
adaptation since I was in grade school
so for me this was really a dream come
true you know it's yeah we are kind of
getting a little bizarre with the meta
Christopher Pike world he does seem to
exist in the universe of the show
um but we couldn't help it you know like
any chance to get those cool paperbacks
some screen time I wanted to do that we
even had them in Midnight Mass we can
expect a little something different from
us because it's a little more fun than
some of our other shows a little lighter
which is we were really excited to do
and it's we were excited about the kind
of Youth of our cast because this is a
little bit of a different thing for us
audience wise so you know and the other
thing is like because we hope this is an
ongoing Series where some of our other
stuff has been limited so you know God
willing and a whole bunch of people
watch it we'll have another season you
know that dealing with the the cash is
one of the best things about this show
some of these actors this is their first
job ever
um seeing the whole process you know
through their eyes and feeling their
excitement and their passion for it it
was really reinvigorating in a lot of
ways and I heard a lot of the older cast
members saying the same thing this cast
is so Dynamic there is some incredible
incredible performances in the show I
feel very lucky to have been kind of a
rung on their ladder you know this is
this is really cool
foreign